and it came to pass guys read this
Joshua 513- 15 Read with me and it came
to pass when Joshua was by Jericho that
he lifted up his eyes and looked behold
there stood a man over against him with
a sorn drawn in his hand notice he sees
a man a human figure with a sword like
the angel of the Lord appears as a human
figure in a human body with a sword in
his hand okay
watch behold there stood a man over
against him with a sword drawn in his
hand and Josh went unto him and said
unto him art thou for us or for our
adversaries are you fighting for me or
are you fighting for my enemies notice
the answer guys notice the answer by
this man and I'm going to show you Jesus
Christ in a minute and he said nay but
as captain of the host of the Lord no
I'm neither for you nor against you pay
attention I'm not for you nor against
you you're going to see why that's meet
I'm not for you nor against you I'm the
command
of the host of the Lord I command the
armies of God the armies of God in
heaven on Earth under my command I rule
them his Heavenly armies his Earthly
armies under my authority so as the
commander of the host of the Lord am I
now come now notice what Joshua does
Joshua fell on his face to the Earth and
did
worship and said unto him what saith my
Lord unto a servant what
wow you are my Lord I am your servant
slave and I bow down in worship to
you now notice 15 what he says notice 15
what he
says and the captain of the Lord so said
unto Joshua loose thy shoe from thy foot
from off thy foot remove your shoes from
me for the place where on thou standest
is Holy and Joshua did so wow did you
catch it
the commander the captain of the army of
the Lord says I don't fight for you nor
do I fight against you I command God's
armies in heaven and earth I command you
you fight for me you're my servant my
slave doing my bidding Joshua Falls
before him on his face in worship and
says you are my Lord I'm your servant
I'm here to do what you
want and then he says well the first
thing you do is remove your sandals from
my presence because where I stand that's
sacred ground don't defile it with your
stinking
shoes no it wasn't God who said it Kumi
it was the angel of the Lord who said it
to Moses and that angel is God but not
God the
Father okay are you with me there if
you're focusing did you notice this man
that appeared to Joshua how amazing this
man is notice several things about him
he appears in in human form and he has a
sword in his hand right he is
worshiped Joshua Falls before him on his
face calls him my Lord Adon and says I
am your servant your
slave so that Joshua realize he is my
commander he is my Lord he is my
sovereign he doesn't fight for me I
fight for him because he owns me and
commands me and the armies of Israel and
the armies of heaven and he's worthy of
My Worship
and this man says remove your sandals
from my presence in my presence remove
them because where I am wherever my feet
touch become sacred ground remove your
filthy sandals from my
presence okay why am I unpacking this
okay I want you to show you who this man
is I want to show you who this man is
this man is the angel of God how do I
know make the connection make the
connection with balum when balum saw the
angel of God the veil was removed he saw
the angel of God in human form he saw
the angel of God with a sword in his
hand and like the captain balum fell
before the angel of God on his face and
worship so notice the connection between
the captain Angel the Angel and the
captain appear in human form and have
swords in their hands by which they slay
God's enemies the Angel and the captain
demand worship and receive worship and
another connection between the Angel and
the captain remember what the captain
said he said to him remove your
sandals from my presence because this
ground has become sacred and holy let me
show you what the angel says to Moses
Exodus chapter 3 verses 1- 6
specifically verse 5 Exodus 3 veres 1- 6
specifically verse 5 who appeared to
Moses guys read who appeared to Moses
now Moses kept the flock of Jethro his
father-in-law the priest of Midian and
he led the flock to the backside of the
desert and came to the Mountain of God
even to Horeb now notice who appears to
Moses and the angel of the Lord appeared
oh the angel of the Lord appeared unto
him in a flame of fire out of the midst
of a bush and he looked and behold the
bush burned with fire and the Bush was
not
consumed who appeared to him the angel
of the Lord the angel of the Lord let me
repeat it again the angel of Lord was
appearing to him but now guys read three
and four and Moses said I will now turn
aside and see this great sight why the
bush is not burnt and when the Lord saw
that he turned aside to see God God
called unto him out of the midst of the
Bush wait it said the angel was in the
bush but it says now God is in the bush
calling him from the bush so the angel
is God this God that's appearing is the
Angel so the god that's appearing is the
Angel the angel is God and this God is
the Angel not the
father God called unto him out of the
midst of the Bush and said Moses and
said Moses Moses and he said here am I
now watch what the angel who is God the
angel who is God what does he say in
verse five and he said draw not nigh
hither put off thy
shoes from off thy feet for the place
whereon thou standest is Holy
Ground now notice verse six thank you
Steve God bless you my brother notice
verse
six moreover he said I am the god I am
the God of thy father the god of Abraham
the god of Isaac the god of Jacob and
Moses hit his face for he was afraid to
look upon God guys I'm Blown Away Exodus
3 says it's the angel of God that
appeared as fire out of the Bush but
then it says God spoke out of the Bush
and Moses heard the voice of God and
that voice told him remove your sandals
from my presence and Moses was afraid
because he realized I'm looking at God
inis visible
form but Exodus 3:2 says that's the
angel so are you making the connection
between the Angel and the captain of the
Lord's army the angel like the captain
appears in human form the angel like the
captain has a sword by which he slays
God's enemies the angel like the captain
is worshiped as God the angel like the
captain demands their servants their
subjects to remove their sandals from
their presence why because the angel is
the captain the captain is the
Angel
right did that sink in making sense
before I move
on I want to give you a minute for it to
sink
in so who is the captain of the army of
the Lord he's the angel of the Lord who
is the Angel of the Lord
the captain of the army of the
Lord the captain of the army of the Lord
is the Angel of the Lord the angel of
God is the captain of the army of the
Lord they're the same
person yes he was there with the father
Christos and the pillar of cloud Pillar
of Fire it wasn't just the angel it was
God and His Angel together in the cloud
so yes the father and the son so did
everyone see that Joshua 5: 13- 15
that captain of the army of the Lord is
the angel of God did I make the case
there or you're still not seeing it
because now I'm going to show you it's
Jesus I'm going to show you it's
Jesus if there's someone still not
getting it let me know because now I'm
going to show you it's
Jesus let's go back to Joshua
5:13 because now I'm going to prove to
you that one is Jesus Christ appearing
to them as the father messenger in human
form who claims to be God does things
that only God can do whom others realize
this is God in human form invisible form
worthy of our worship okay now Joshua
5:13 watch
here and it came to pass when Joshua was
by Jericho that he lifted up his eyes
and looked and behold there stood a man
over against him with a sword drawn in
his hand and Joshua went unto him and
said unto him art thou for us or for our
adversaries a man appearing in human
form with a sword who is verse 14 verse
14 who is he watch I'm going to show you
it's Jesus but bear with me I'm going to
walk you through this verse 14 and he
said nay but as captain of the host of
the Lord the word host is the term the
Bible uses for the armies of God whether
his Heavenly armies meaning his Angelic
Warriors or his Earthly
armies like Israel fighting for God he
goes I'm the captain of God's armies in
heaven on Earth the armies in heaven are
under my authority the armies on Earth
under my authority I am the lord of the
Army in heaven I rule over them and I am
the Lord of God's Army on Earth meaning
you Joshua and Israel I Am Lord over you
I tell you what to do so he is the
commander of the army of Heaven how do I
know this is
Jesus according to the New Testament who
commands the armies of Heaven
who is the lord of the armies of Heaven
who owns the army of Heaven Revelation
19 veres
11-6 re Revelation 19 veres
11-6 watch
here Read With Me Now guys read with me
and I saw heaven open and behold a white
horse and he that sat upon him was
called faithful and true and in
righteousness he doth judge and make War
his eyes were as a flame of fire and on
his head were many crowns and he had a
name written that no man knew but he
himself and he was clothed with a
vesture dipped in Blood and his name is
called the word of
God so this is Jesus the word of God
it's not God the father and the armies
which were in heaven followed him he's
leading the armies of Heaven he's their
Commander they followed him the leader
the commander who's in charge and they
were upon white horses clothed in fine
linen white and clean now watch
15 Read With Me 15 and out of his mouth
goeth a sharp sword so he has a sword
too that with it he should Smite the
Nations and he shall rule them with a
rod of iron and he treadeth The Wine
Press of the fierceness and Wrath of
almighty God and now notice his other
title revelation 1916 and he hath on his
vesture and on his thigh a name written
king of kings and Lord of lords there
you
go Jesus the word of God King of Kings
Lord of lords leads the armies of heaven
and owns them Revelation 19:19
Revelation
1919 pay attention guys no side talking
pay attention so you can learn
Revelation 19:19 and I saw the Beast and
the King of the earth and their armies
gathered together to make war against
him that sat on on the horse and against
his
army Jesus on the horse and it's his
army he owns the armies He commands the
armies he is Lord of the armies he's the
king over all kings and Lord over all
Lords and if you're still doubt it's
Jesus even though it says the word of
God which is the name of Jesus
Revelation 17:14 who is this word of God
who's the king of kings Lord of lords
who owns the armies of Heaven Revelation
17:14 there shall make war with the lamb
and the lamb shall overcome them for he
is Lord of lords and king of kings and
they that are with him are called and
chosen and faithful the lamb the word of
God is King of Kings Lord of lords and
he owns the armies of heaven so whom did
Joshua see and worship whom did Moses
see and worship
Jesus Christ in his prehuman existence
before he was born as a baby from his
Blessed Virgin mother before he became
an actual human by Nature appearing in
the Old Testament in visible form as
fire or in a pillar of cloud or pillar
Fire by night or in human
form that was Jesus